mientras que desde el palacio del elíseo
justifica la visita del presidente
manuel macrón a quien como un
espaldarazo necesario al pueblo
ucraniano y también como parte de las
funciones que tiene francia mientras
ejerce la presidencia temporal de la
unión europea hasta fines de mes los
adversarios políticos del presidente
manuel macro no coinciden en encontrar
más bien un objetivo electoral este
viaje a tres días de la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones legislativas álex y
todavía de la francia en su misa al
partido de realismo masón cree que hay
efectivamente un trasfondo electoral
dice que no quiere que los mártires
ucranianos sean usados para una
operación de política interna en el
francia y que este viaje le sirve el
presidente manuel macrón para ponerse
nuevamente en escena en la extrema
derecha marine lepén coincide dice que
no le parece raro que macro na viaje a
ucrania pero sí que lo haga ahora podría
haberlo hecho hace diez días y eso hace
pensar obviamente en un transfondo para
ella electoral desde el partido de
derecha los republicanos su presidente
christian rakos dice que la diplomacia
no frente a las cámaras y le parece que
este viaje es una puesta en escena
ridícula del presidente manuel macro y
finalmente también en el partido de los
republicanos jean françois copé alcalde
de moi quien fuera presidente del
partido se preocupa de otro punto de
vista él dice que en estos momentos
francia está amenazada por la hiper
extrema izquierda y que el presidente
macrón se va de viaje la casa se quema y
macrón mira para otro lado